j'ai le gouvernement dans le cadre de la
révision des lois de bioéthique a prévu
d'instaurer la procréation médicalement
assistée pour les couples de femmes ou
pour les femmes seules
en revanche emmanuel macron l'a dit et
répété il n'est pas question d'autoriser
en france la gestation pour autrui c'est
à dire les mères porteuses mais il ya
des personnalités médiatiques qui font
campagne pour la gp 1 c'est le cas
notamment de marc olivier fogiel notre
confrère date elle qui avec un livre sur
ce sujet pour raconter son expérience
personnelle
samedi dernier sur le plateau d'on n'est
pas couché l'émission de france 2 muriel
robin actrice et humoriste est venu en
quelque sorte conforter fogiel en
égratignant du même coup un autre
chroniqueur de l'émission qui s'appelle
charles consigny et qui lui est contre
la gpa
on revient sur ce sujet mais d'abord on
regarde des images mais je trouve que
c'est formidable d'être alleaume je
crois que quelque chose qui c'est parti
la machine est lancée et tea party
parfois malheureusement ton livre m'a
beaucoup aidé à éclairer ce que je me
dis tiens donc il ya des femmes du pop 0
tiens il ya des femmes c'est peut-être
possible qu'il a couru tient sans
répandre si on pense en l'afrique
un enfant qui arrivait enfin tout le
monde parce que ce que je sais que pour
ça je peux vous voulez dire simplement
d'après vous la parole jusqu'au bout de
vous dire l'arrogance ça me fait mal
finalement
voilà l'arrogance c'était pour schalke
uncini marin de viry c'est étonnant
parce que ce discours là il se développe
il se déroule presque naturellement
alors même qu'on pensait qu'il y avait
un consensus contre les mères porteuses
quand il à force de ces personnalités ou
leur aura été supérieure à sa oui quand
on lit même le rapport du conseil
des tic mais cela il exclut totalement
la gpa mais c'est pour mieux dire que la
pma c'est formidable effectivement on
pensait que c'était on pensait que
c'était moi ce que j'en pense simplement
c'est que ils sont pas qualifiés quoi
ils sont pas qualifiés pour ouvrir un
débat démocratique
ils sont pas qualifiés pour parler de
sujets qui sont des sujets
anthropologiquement quand même très
lourd puisqu'il s'agit de la enfin de la
dispersion si je peux dire de la
reproduction enfin delà du fait que
l'enfant ne naît pas d'un père et d'une
mère que et comme elle dit et je suis
frappé quelqu'un mais qu'elle convoque
l'anthropologie africaine là dessus et
qu'elle dise un enfant en afrique qui
naissent et l'enfant de toute la
communauté donc pourquoi pas deux femmes
enfin ou pourquoi pas deux hommes ou
pourquoi pas de d'une communauté parce
que tout est permis avec la gpa on n'y a
pas de yapo quand vous irez sont pas
qualifiés markus vogel part de son
expérience personnelle puisqu'il est
même homosexuel marié et il a deux
petites filles nées de mère porte très
bien et il va donc raconté que c'est le
bonheur et que ça super etc et on
connaît tous des gens qui ont ce genre
d'expérience et c'est pas un problème le
problème il est fin prêt mille politique
la question c'est de savoir quelle est
la règle et ce qu'on accepte cette idée
que des enfants soient faits à
l'extérieur complètement à l'extérieur
de ceux qui ont ensuite devenir leurs
parents au sens social du terme et cette
règle lors elle peut pas se discuter
dans paris match en fin juillet où est
la qualification de paris match ou et le
uss la qualification de paris match et
la qualification de fogiel ou et la
qualification de celle qu'il a
robin enfin d'une certaine façon pour
qui se prend-il c'est ça qui m'a et moi
c'est ça qui me fascine qui pour qui se
prend-il du point de vue de leur
expertise de leur rapport au débat et de
comment dirais-je leur capacité à
intervenir sur quelque chose d'aussi
important d'aussi grave et qui concerne
l'ensemble de la société et même ses
fondements anthropologiques enfin j'y
vois là on parle de fogiel et muriel
robin on parle pas de bla on parle de
gens qui sont sympathiques mais qui
n'ont pas forcément des idées très
approfondie sur le saut vers une soulte
à que ce sont des personnalités
extrêmement populaire et dont la voix
compte et alors effectivement ils ne
font pas la loi comme vous intitulé le
sujet était pas question qu'ils fassent
la loi en revanche ils sont exilés la
loi c'est d'avoir médias voilà ils sont
écoutés parce qu'ils font la loi
ils sont écoutés par les responsables
politiques parce qu'effectivement ils
ont une certaine popularité
il représente dans une certaine mesure
l'air du temps donc dans une certaine
mesure
l'air du temps donc dans cette donc ils
sont quand même écouté alors après si
c'est pas eux qui vont influencer mais
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on voit voilà marc
olivier fogiel il a il a eu accès grâce
à son livre c'est vrai qu'il a la une de
paris match il a tf1 - de tous les
grands médias donc obligatoirement au
bout d'un moment c'est ça fuse quand
même dans la société ça peut aussi créer
des réactions contraires mais ça peut
aussi créer de l'empathie de la
compréhension
donc il faut voir que il ya 30 ans par
exemple on voyait pas non plus de
couples homosexuels dans les séries télé
enfin c'est de cet ordre là c'est la
société qui bouge et de temps autant la
société bouge avant les lois alors ça
veut pas dire que c'est eux qui sont
légitimes pour la faire bouger mais ils
peuvent participer à la faire bouger et
fabrique vous pensez qu'il ya une une
forme de stratégie c'est à dire que par
exemple on peut penser que fogiel sort
son livre au moment où il ya la
discussion de la loi sur la pma parce
que lui est favorable à ce que on aller
encore plus loin ont d'abord le
le débat sur la pma est régulièrement
repoussées donc je veux dire il a
peut-être pas non plus calculer
exclusivement là dessus en tout cas je
ne sais pas ses motivations par rapport
à ça moi ça me donne comme impression
c'est que on a un peu interdit le débat
sur la gpa et je pense qu'on est dans
une société aujourd'hui où on ne peut
plus bannir a priori un débat ça doit
être quelque chose qui est conclusif epa
introductif c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on a dit la gpa non mais sans aller dans
le débat lui même et je pense que quand
on fait ça aujourd'hui cette société ne
tient pas sur cette valeur et c'est en
gros c'est tabou si un moment de n'y a
pas de démonstration s'il ya pas
d'affirmations s'il n'y a pas d'argument
or aujourd'hui le risque de ne pas avoir
fait le débat de ne pas l'avoir porté
avec les difficultés qui a parce qu'il
ya le débat théorique mais il ya aussi
le sort par exemple des enfants qui sont
nés de gpa et qui existent et qui sont
bien là aujourd'hui c'est une vraie
question et qui mérite aussi d'être
posée peut-être dans d'autres termes
d'ailleurs que celles de certaines
émissions télé mais est ce que
finalement à interdire un débat on sait
pas donner aussi un moment donné les
moyens entre guillemets d'avoir des faux
débats d'avoir des débats qui sont mal
posée et qui sont portés par des
personnes qui certes ou un rapport
personnel avec le sujet mais qui ne le
pose pas avec la distance qu aurait
mérité ce débat on l'a eu déjà ce
sentiment là eu au moment du pacs on
nous a dit non mais pas le mariage vous
savez ce sera pas possible au moment du
mariage pour tous et de l'adoption on a
eu surtout pas la pma finalement la pma
on va avoir le débat et ça va faire un
espèce et là tout d'un coup il ya la gpa
et je pense que interdire le débat sera
un moment donné nous a mis dans une
situation compliquée parce que je pense
que la société a besoin à un moment
donné qu'on n'arrive pas simplement sur
il ya un tabou mais plutôt il ya une
démonstration et on arrive au final à
dire que on est sur ce débat moi j'ai
vraiment cette sensation qu'aujourd'hui
ceux qui portent le débat le porte parce
qu'il n'est pas poser ailleurs de
manière sérieuse
oui sauf le nom que là le débat s'ouvre
mais les anticiper à ils font pas la une
de paris match parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
notoriété de marc-olivier projet lors de
l'émission de ruquier il
ça fait pas la série bat vraiment choqué
je vous savez en partie du débat
politique il ya des personnalités
s'engage là pour cette je vais appeler
cette cause mais il y en a plein qui
s'engagent pour plein de cause alors
personnellement que ce soit celles là
ont d'autres ça ne m'intéresse pas parce
que je suis pas influencer par ne sont
pas influencés par le fait que madame
bernadette chirac aime les pièces jaunes
que
une réelle robin est une tradition sur
la gpa non mais voilà mai mais
effectivement ça suscite
ça contribue à 1,15 accor a incarné une
cause et écopé et à la rendre populaire
sûr mais quelle est la capacité
contributive
excusez moi mais c'est dans le débat de
muriel robin et de faire et je suis
d'accord mais non mais ça c'est d'accord
avec vous mais france je crois pas non
plus de raison de deux légitimes de
larrau qualifiés non plus la santé qui
sont pas les disqualifier va se mettre à
leur place c'est à dire à la place de
témoignages d'une expérience heureuse
pour projet elle très bien parfait ça
doit exister voilà mais met donc ça fait
partie du débat s'est déplacé ya une
personnalité
il ya des personnalités qui se sont le
plus proches des opposants à la gpa
qu'elle s'exprime est ce que la question
de travail qui en a eu à ce qu'elles le
feront et oui pourquoi elles le font pas
est ce que le débat se fait de manière
serein ce raid est ce que toutes les
positions peuvent s'exprimer de manière
équitable j'en suis pas complètement
convaincu mais là on a vu aussi que les
opposants à la gpa cij et considère pas
raccourci que c'était les mêmes que ceux
posés à la manif au mariage pour tous
donc la manif pour tous
ils sont trouver les moyens de se faire
en tant qu il fallait se faire entendre
c'est ça fait partie du débat
démocratique ya plusieurs façons de
s'exprimer personnellement je joue pas
ils peuvent pas très un grand
enthousiasme de ses débats j'ai pas vu
ce que les past émission donc j'ai pas
vu ma voix la montre et c'est tous les
samedis soirs avec laurent ruquier de
l'est les commentaires sur twitter
selon vous ça c'est la question qu'on
vous a posé les personnalités publiques
ont-elles une influence dans les débats
sociétaux bas vous ne répondez oui aux
deux tiers
et puis voici quelques commentaires pour
jf déconnectés de la réalité
elle ne cherche qu'à promouvoir leur
vision de la société idéale et souvent
par la même occasion leur carrière
beaucoup d'internautes le 10 comme si
cela gpa est au final déjà programmés et
brownie de l'odyssée people anime le
débat public dans le sens où ils veulent
juste se mettre sur le devant de la
scène les babineau ajoute loyal robin
s'érigeant porte parole des français
je trouve cela assez déplacé peut-être
marin de viry que c'est parce que le
débat strictement politique est
difficile à organiser sur ces sujets par
exemple sur la pma ou
notamment les gens de droite j'en
connais quelques-uns qui sont plutôt
opposées ont pas envie de venir en
première ligne parce que ils ont ils
vont avoir l'impression d'être contre le
progrès ou de pas avoir de coeur j'ai
pas d'être contre le progrès c'est de
savoir quelles qu'aient comment
dirais-je qu'elle contrôle que l'on veut
de la technique dans son existence
c'est ça la gpa d'ailleurs comme la pma
de ce point de vue là c'est au fond ce
confié à la technique médicale
cette capacité humaine que nous avons de
reproduire
bon c'est un débat philosophique profond
la question de savoir si la technique
nous devons nous y soumettre nous y
soumettre ou en tout cas l'utiliser à
des fins qui sont des fins particulières
quoi voilà bon c'est pas un débat qui
peut être comme ça pose et enfin qu'il
doit être posée me semble-t-il avec
dignité avec et qui doit et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous qui doit
être posée à fond on doit parler là on
doit parler de la de la gpa on doit en
parler à fond
voilà et puis à ce moment là on verra ce
qu'il en sort et s'il en sort ou font
que seul le désir d'enfant est une sorte
de le désir d'enfant et le principe
d'égalité entre les couples homosexuels
et les couples hétérosexuels ça c'est
plus particulièrement pour la pme est
quelque chose qui voilà qui fait la loi
à ce moment là très bien c'est le désir
d'enfant et le principe d'égalité entre
homosexuels et hétérosexuels qui fait la
loi et ça n'est pas forcément l'idée
qu'on pourrait se faire de l'intérêt de
l'enfant d'avoir un père enfin une
origines paternelles et une origine
maternelle très bien mais au moins le
débat sera tranché poser comme ça et ça
aura été instruit de cette manière là et
d'autres manières aussi qu'ils sont
possibles mais c'est à ce niveau là
qu'il faut le faire venir c'est à ce
niveau de réflexion faut le faire c'est
pas chez machin là comment il s'appelle
bon ok écoutez c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire ce soir c'est de poser le débat
comme écornée merci à tous les casques
de l'avoir permis point de vue c'est
fini pour ce soir à demain même heure
même endroit bonsoir à tous
[Musique]